But there's another way to create herd immunity without such a high cost of life.
Let's reset the clock to the moment the WHO declared the pandemic.
This time, governments and communities around the world slow the spread of the virus...
...to give research facilities time to produce a vaccine.
They buy this crucial time...
...through tactics that may include widespread testing to identify carriers,...
...quarantining the infected and people they've interacted with, and physical distancing.
Even with these measures in place, the virus slowly spreads,...
...causing up to hundreds of thousands of deaths.
Some cities get the outbreak under control and go back to business as usual,...
...only to have a resurgence...
...and return to physical distancing when a new case passes through.
Within the next several years,...
...one or possibly several vaccines become widely and hopefully freely available...
...thanks to a worldwide effort.
Once 40 to 90% of the population has received it,...
...the precise amount varying based on the virus,...
...herd immunity kicks in, and the pandemic fizzles out.
Let's rewind the clock one more time, to consider the final strategy:...
...coordinate and crush.
The idea here is to simultaneously starve the virus everywhere...
...through a combination of quarantine, social distancing and restricting travel.
The critical factor is to synchronize responses.
In a typical pandemic, when one country is peaking,...
...another may be getting its first cases.
Instead of every leader responding to what's happening in their jurisdiction,...
...here, everyone must treat the world as the giant interconnected system it is.
If coordinated properly, this could end a pandemic in just a few months...
...with low loss of life.